[Music]
did you always want to perform you seem
like such a natural performer did you
want to perform like when you were a kid
when you stood in acting yeah it was you
know and high school I got really
serious about it and I did a speech and
plays and I was in this community
program called break the cycle because
my town of Longmont was a target city
for the most teenage pregnancies in
Colorado so we had tips I don't know if
our teens were sexy or bored or probably
both right and they're like we got to do
something we got to have an outreach
theater program and it was called break
the cycle and I was in it couldn't wait
and we did little shows and sketches
about you know safe sex and stay away
from drugs and domestic violence and we
also had this diversity piece where we'd
like start off in a seed because it was
really artistic and then the music would
come and we'd grow out of the seed you
know and then we'd come out and each
person would say like my name is Jason
and I'm Native American you know just
like whatever made them different and I
didn't I didn't have anything so my
director I was like a white girl who
like loved play like I'm a white girl
who loves plays my director wanted that
you know drama it up a little bit so
she's like hey how about you have AIDS
so like you guy wanna you cut my teeth
on this yeah well so we did the show you
only grow out of this out of our seeding
like I'm Jason I'm Native American yo
I'm Suzanne I'm half white and half
Mexican I'm Anna and I'm pregnant
obviously and then like I'm Kristen and
I have AIDS and afterward the bomb is is
everybody was what they were except for
me
this poor woman comes up to me in tears
and she's just like I just got a call
this morning you're so brave my nephew
is tested positive for HIV it I just
hope you can get through this and what I
should have said was oh oh you'll get
through it
thanks man but instead I was just like
17 so I was like oh no no lady I don't
have AIDS that's just the play you know
her report about a poor nephew in and
the end like in that moment I don't
think I've ever wanted AIDS more in high
school
normal life in high school cuz you you
you know did you did you you know date
guys in high school and I don't go out
you know normal guys normal guys no no
guys I don't know guys weren't into this
it was tough I think guys in high school
we forgot to do this supposed to go like
this I think guys in high school are
very insecure and they're just starting
to date and they and they don't want to
get it wrong you know wrong so they go
by what's in select society considers
hot not hot and I wasn't I wasn't hot I
was like my own hot which was a very
specific hot to me
still rock you know was there one guy in
your life there are several crushes look
there was one that I really loved and I
remember we did like forensics debate
together what your audience will know
cities and debate and it's it's really
competitive and we were a team and I
just everything he said I soaked it up
and I stored it away everything and we
were like riding back from Wyoming on
the bus and and I said something like
yeah that's like that time when you
scratched your blue truck you got for
your birthday and he was like oh you
remember everything and I was like oh
yeah I do I remember everything you've
ever told me he's like yeah like what
and then I just proceeded to unleash oh
my god your birthday you got pink guy
like it was coming out it's coming out
it didn't stop for like 20 minutes and
he was terrified like I was like what do
you what do you remember about me like
what I've told you he's like oh I don't
I think you got like a brother
[Laughter]